already we're trying to figure out ways
of blending the Practical and digital
since we know you all love stranger
things so much we've decided to put
together an ultimate behind the scenes
guide to some of the most interesting
aspects of the making of the series
every series has a start but how did
Stranger Things become so successful
it's all about the right cast and
changing with the times
let's do this number one The Heart of
stranger things is its cast without the
perfect dynamic between the five kids
specifically the series would not have
been as successful the first thing The
Duffer brothers did was hire casting
director Carmen Kuba and they did not
even second guess her amazing abilities
with the kid dispatch it was about
authenticity and these kids felt like
genuine kids once she was able to nail
down the series regulars a couple of the
kiddos reunited with some familiar faces
at the table read both Gayton Matarazzo
and Caleb McLaughlin knew each other
before on Broadway and later on for
season two they caught up with Annie
herself Sadie sink and in most instances
Broadway had already discovered them
David Harbor and winoa Ryder were shuins
to the casting director but they were
still asked to audition like everyone
else and as the seasons rolled on
casting was able to attract only the
best of the best cough cough Eddie
Munson number 2 as a series evolves so
does the CGI budget and this show had to
prove they could earn that big budget as
films get more expensive to make Studios
and investors want to be cheaper when
The Duffer Brothers had their ideas for
the demogorgon they were faced with the
problem of a lower budget and very
expensive CGI bfx started with complex
3D models of the creature and pretty
much nailed the design on their first
try the detail the level of detail and
printers I couldn't even imagine that
you could actually get in a printer
after the initial process the question
arose as to whether or not to make a
suit or just make the creature digitally
after intense discussions the brothers
decided it was best to make a full CG
character due to the fact that not even
the expert actor playing the monster
could do it they realized that as they
were moving on it had to do things a
practical guy and students can't do
number three working with children on
set can work one of two ways you suck it
up and deal with the hyperactivity or
you get cast next to some real
professional kiddos and become a father
figure well that's exactly what happened
when David Harbor was cast as Hopper it
started out a little rough for him in
season one but as his character grew
closer to the kids so did he on a
serious tip I mean I am very protective
of this kid seriously though he's a much
better Papa than papa will ever be to
11. number 4. Joe Kiri was a little too
excited to beat the shadow monster out
of Charlie Heaton but being that
Jonathan was never possessed by the
shadow monster it seemed like a good
change of plan to have heat and get some
revenge on Steve The Duffer Brothers
originally had Jonathan being punched
and pushed around by Steve but to
Jonathan's benefits they changed it up
for his character's Arc they went at
this scene for a long time and Kiri
actually received a few shiners from the
incident luckily for Joe he wasn't
getting himself into too many tussles as
the show went on I was like all swollen
under underneath the makeup then it was
number five okay so season one was a
massive success now the big boys CGI
budget is granted and with that in mind
the VFX artists could now make the
shadow monster this massive creature was
of course all digital but how did they
film Will's possession simple create a
green screen setup and have a Young Noah
schnapp react with season 2 as a whole
the CGI was upped substantially all due
to a very successful opening and with
that being said we all know how amazing
the VFX work was in Seasons three and
four number six we guess we have Millie
Bobby Brown to thank for this fan
favorite moment on the day they filmed
the Snowball Dance both Millie and Finn
wolfhard were ready to dance it up but
one person was not settling for the
awkward Middle School Waltz Millie
wanted this moment for the fans right
before they were about to film she
called the director over with a little
kiss request the director was unsure at
the moment and only agreed with her over
a loud Mega phone okay Millie and Finn
are gonna kiss in all seriousness this
gave Millie a sense of control over her
character's Journey giving a lot more
input to The Duffer Brothers to write
the next seasons number seven season
three was a big one they included
everything from the upside down Army to
the complex underground lab as CGI was
only getting more involved as each
season passed this set in particular
stayed practical the actors sneaking
into the Russian Lab were shocked by its
authenticity this was one of the first
times The Stranger Things cast
experienced such a high level of
production caliber but they were not
prepared for what was in store for
season four number eight sometimes
Productions just hire stun people for
the heck of it and this time jokeri was
all in to throw down and after his
little brawl in season 1 stun
coordinators were more than confident he
could fend for himself with only a few
hours of rehearsal for the scene in
which Steve fights a Russian song
Soldier he was tossed in to roll with
the punches Joe of course nailed it
after a few takes but for that poor
stuntman he had to bash his head on a
table each time but he didn't go home
empty-handed each time they do it I
think they get paid so they're like you
want to do it again he's like oh yeah
let's do it one more time number nine
ask the technology grew the way to get a
CGI monster got a whole lot easier to
execute on set what better than a beach
ball to get the job done we get that
it's probably a little strange for a big
production to use such a method but we
guess they ran out of tracking objects
and just grabbed the first thing they
could find it certainly did the trick
and the actors look genuinely scared of
that beach ball as silly as this sounds
it looks like production was going easy
on those kiddos before bringing in the
real Beck now for season four number 10
so much work gets put in the stranger
things so the sets of every season
needed to be top-notch well with each
season the more practical each that got
as season 4 began filming production
spent months creating everything
practical that they could they actually
made two separate versions of the creel
house then ending it with its
semi-destructional look a more
interesting scent was that of the
demogorgon Arena which featured a fully
practical design for the actors to
survive in there are tons of other set
pieces to mention but each one had the
common factor of housing light well as
light is a very crucial aspect of the
series in general number 11 when you're
running up that CGI Hill there is no
coming down as they raised Sadie sink on
the day of this graveyard scene it
wasn't like the director said Sadie just
hop in the harness real quick no sync
was put through a lot of prep time in
the rehearsal space for this and on the
day she was filming the scene on
location she nailed it like this is the
most elaborate form of harness
harnessing that I've ever done it's
amazing to see Sadie Singh grow up so
quick weekly from skateboard stunts to
harness stunts high up in the air number
12 The Duffer Brothers wanted their
night King and visual effects artist
Barry Gower was going to deliver they
said to us we want our own iconic
villain we need our Strange Things
version of the night King since the
duffers wanted this creature to have
humanoid features Gower created a full
cast of Bauer he then created the suit
material out of a soft weighty material
cutting it up into sections but not all
of vector's suit was soft they fitted
Jaime with a quite uncomfy mechanical
cloth structure that fit into one of his
hands this gave the character those
ominous claws to effectively take some
teenager souls to the upside down to top
it all off why not slather him in some
lube some of the other cast members that
come up shake his hand and just regret
it immediately number 13 a scene like
this requires everyone to hit their
marks if there's even one step wrong
it's back to one for that shootout scene
in season 4 the director made sure to
have lengthy rehearsals with the actors
to make sure they hit every moment right
but unfortunately if it can happen it
will happen and just as they were about
to get a perfect first take one of the
soldiers missed their Mark and they had
to go back and do it all over again
although the initial filming was a
little rough it really did open the door
of imagination for the crew would they
have even attempted this in season one
number 14 how does one create vechnus
trippy hell Lair one a lot of CGI and
two a lot of fake blood and now that
their set design skills have evolved the
crew was really able to pour their
hearts into this one they built the main
set practically and filled in the rest
with CGI but Sadie sync had a problem no
it was in factna her main problem was
running through a bunch of slippery fake
blood that layered The Sound Stage she
got more of a workout in one day than
she you would have had in a whole week
yikes number 15 creating costumes for a
series of The Stranger Things magnitude
and creating backups for backup costumes
only gets more stressful season after
season costume designer Amy Paris
considered every option carefully when
dressing the characters specifically for
season 4 Amy's job would get a lot more
tedious she gathered everything she knew
regarding each character's mood and
scene environment her coolest costume
yet was her take on 11's outfit for the
roller rink Scene It dried and it dried
well and so we actually use that and
that's the dress she's actually wearing
Millie had personal input on the initial
outfit design but when it came time for
the milkshake to be thrown Paris had to
make sure the real milkshake dried
correctly on the outfit to make sure it
kept fine during the rest of the scene's
brown wore it in but what about her
stunt doubles well she assigned another
designer to replicate the exact same
stain for another outfit we had our
Adrian Dyer Gale paint an exact replica
of the milkshake the team behind
stranger things has revolutionized Film
Production value for television shows
who knew all that work would create a
mere hour of each episode everything had
to change as the kids grew up and with
the announcement of season five we can
be sure they'll make it even bigger were
you surprised by how they made a
specific aspect of the series if so
leave a comment below